[Música]
bienvenidos aquí comienza la crónica de
medio ambiente soy María Clara calle y
Hoy les mostraré algunos ejemplos de
cómo la tecnología está ayudando a
combatir la crisis ambiental chile
padeció uno de los peores desastres
causados por incendios forestales con
más de 700.000 hectáreas quemadas allí
un equipo especializado utilizó drones y
análisis de clima y topografía para
combatir las llamas la historia desde
nuestra corresponsal Patricia Luna
Esta es la unidad militar de emergencia
hume desplegada en los incendios de
chile 50 miembros del ejército español
especializados en el uso de tecnología
para el combate del fuego aquí los dron
son los protagonistas se usan para
vigilancia y extinción de incendios de
gran magnitud y difícil Control El cabo
Álvaro Fernández es uno de los
operadores de los vuelos que cuentan con
telemetría y cámaras térmicas y que
ofrecen datos como la altitud de las
llamas su intensidad dirección el cambio
de viento la propagación del fuego la
cantidad de combustible o vegetación o
los focos subyacentes bajo tierra que no
podrían observarse a vista simple en el
terreno y que son claves en la
estrategia
un poco todo eso nosotros lo vemos y
directamente como encima en avanzando lo
están viendo el vuelo real en directo lo
analizan y demás y ya no van diciendo
las órdenes en walkie una de las comunas
de la región sureña del bío bío más
afectadas por el fuego la ume tiene su
centro de operaciones aquí se toman
decisiones sobre cómo se va a enfrentar
los focos del día minimizando los
riesgos de los brigadistas en terreno y
se comparten estos datos con otras sedes
donde se toman decisiones a nivel global
El capitán Iván espeso es uno de los que
tienen las tareas de adjudicar
estrategias de combate análisis
de la meteorología se hace un análisis
de la topografía de la zona donde donde
se va a trabajar
fundamentalmente eso y si tenemos datos
se hace un análisis también de los
combustibles los más favorecidos por
esta información privilegiada son las
unidades en terreno que se dedican a
poner el hombro y pelear contra las
llamas el subteniente Pimentel estuvo a
cargo de las operaciones en una jornada
extenuante para esta brigada que acarrea
la experiencia de otros incendios en
España hemos aprendido que el trabajo de
los drones es fundamental ya que nos dan
una visión general de lo que es el
perímetro del incendio Dónde están los
focos calientes y demás zonas de humo
posibles días de acceso datos y
productos de inteligencia con los que
combatir unos incendios que en chile se
alargan ya por más de 20 días y que
parecen no tener fin los drones no solo
sirven contra los incendios su
tecnología de estabilización está en un
bote que sobrevuela el agua el modelo s8
de la compañía sueca Candela es una
lancha de motor eléctrico con hidroalas
que le permiten levantarse de la
superficie Marina esto genera menos
fricción y hace que se necesite un 80%
menos de energía también emite un 99%
menos de CO2 que el resto sus baterías
vienen de un carro 100% eléctrico el
polstar 2 una marca de la sueca Volvo
con esa batería el bote viaja 100
kilómetros por carga equivalentes a 57
millas náuticas cerca del doble de otros
botes eléctricos pero la solución es
poca Pues los barcos recreativos son
poco usados aún así el jefe ejecutivo de
canela cree que la solución a los
problemas ambientales está en la
tecnología
esa misma idea Está en el primer reporte
global sobre la eliminación de dióxido
de carbono este estudio liderado por la
universidad de Oxford enfatiza En que si
queremos limitar el calentamiento global
a dos o a uno coma cinco grados Celsius
como plantea el acuerdo de París es
necesario reducir las emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero y a la par
eliminar el CO2 que ya hay en la
atmósfera pero hasta ahora pocos países
se han preocupado por adelantar En esta
segunda vía la investigación de
Mobile señala que es necesario eliminar
cada año
0,96 GB de dióxido de carbono de la
cerca de 40 que se emiten anualmente en
el mundo sin embargo con las promesas
ambientales que tienen hoy los países o
ndc por sus siglas en inglés de aquí a
2030 se eliminarán entre 0,1 y 0,65 gb
Es por eso que el informe afirma que hay
una brecha
para cerrarla Proponen aumentar las
tecnologías que existen para capturar
CO2 y que son mínimas en comparación a
los métodos convencionales y es que los
convencionales atrapan hasta dos mil
millones de toneladas de CO2 es decir 2
giga toneladas mientras que los
novedosos tan solo atrapan 2 millones
320 mil toneladas
cuando el estudio habla de métodos
convencionales se refiere por ejemplo a
sembrar más árboles para que estos
atrapen dióxido de carbono una función
que también cumplen los humedales y que
se fortalece con la agro silvicultura en
la que se trabaja ganado y bosque
Aunque estas prácticas son las más
usadas Los investigadores sostienen que
si no se aumentan Las capturas de CO2
con tecnología difícilmente cumpliremos
con las metas del acuerdo de París esos
métodos novedosos incluyen la bioenergía
con captura y almacenamiento de carbono
que quema grandes cantidades de bosques
para convertir el CO2 que capturaron los
árboles en energía las dax y la dac por
sus siglas en inglés secuestran el
dióxido que hay en el aire a través de
solventes químicos y hay otras apuestas
en los océanos como la alcalinización
que lanza sustancias alcalinas al mar
para aumentar su pH y combatir la
acidificación o la fertilización con
hierro para incrementar así el plancton
que captura CO2 hoy otra idea aún más
fuera de serie es la meteorización
mejorada que acelera el proceso natural
que tarda millones de años pues es
triturar rocas de silicato para que su
arcilla secuestre dióxido pero muchos
otros científicos dudan de estas
soluciones porque son muy costosas y
porque se tardarán décadas en
desarrollarlas aún así la tecnología
puede traer salidas ambientales hasta
aquí La Crónica nos vemos la otra semana